JOHN?
>> WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS.
IT IS INVOLVING BRONNY JAMES,
THE 19-YEAR-OLD SON OF THE
FOUR-TIME NBA CHAMPION LeBRON
JAMES.
WE ARE LEARNING THAT BRONNY
JAMES WHO IS GOING TO BE A
FRESHMAN BASKETBALL PLAYER AT
USC SUFFERED CARDIAC ARREST
WHILE AT A PRACTICE YESTERDAY.
LET ME READ A STATEMENT THAT WAS
JUST PROVIDED TO US BY THE
FAMILY.
YESTERDAY WHILE PRACTICING,
BRONNY JAMES SUFFERED A CARDIAC
ARREST, AND MEDICAL STAFF WAS
ABLE TO TREAT BRONNY AND TAKE
HIM TO THE HOSPITAL.
HE IS NOW IN STABLE CONDITION
AND NO LONGER IN THE ICU.
WE ASK FOR RESPECT AND PRIVACY
FOR THE JAMES FAMILY, AND WE
WILL UPDATE THE MEDIA WHEN THERE
IS MORE INFORMATION, AND LeBRON
AND SAVANNAH, THE PARENTS OF
BRONNY, WISH TO SEND THE DEEPEST
THANKS TO THE USC STAFF FOR
INCREDIBLE WORK AND DEDICATION
TO THE SAFETY OF THEIR ATHLETES.
SO CARDIAC ARREST AT PRACTICE
YESTERDAY.
AND CRUCIALLY, RESTING
COMFORTABLY AND NO LONGER IN THE
ICU.
DR. SANJAY GUPTA IS WITH US, AND
ANDY SCHOLES AS WELL, AND NOW,
YOU GIVE US A STATEMENT OF WHAT
THIS MEANS TO YOU.
>> WELL, SO, HE IS 18 YEARS OLD,
AND SOUNDS LIKE HE HAD A SUDDEN
CARDIAC ARREST, AND THERE WAS A
VERY FAST IT SOUNDS LIKE
RESUSCITATION.
TAKEN TO THE HOSPITAL.
BUT, AS YOU ARE POINTS OUT GIVEN
THAT HE WAS IN THE INTENSIVE
CARE UNIT, AND ABLE TO LEAVE THE
INTENSIVE CARE UNIT, AND GO TO
THE GENERAL FLOOR, AND THIS IS
THE IMPORTANT HEADLINE THERE,
AND THE CARDIAC ARREST AND WHAT
TRIGGEREDED THAT IS WHAT THE
DOCTORS WILL BE INVESTIGATING
OVER THE NEXT SEVERAL DAYS.
THIS IS RARE.
WE KNOW THAT A FEW THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO ARE YOUNG ATHLETES DO
SUFFER SUDDEN CARDIAC ARREST
EVERY YEAR, AND SO MANY
DIFFERENT REASONS THAT CAN
HAPPEN, AND ABNORMALITIES OF THE
ELECTRIC IMPULSES OF THE HEART.
AND WITH LAMAR HAMLIN, IT WAS
KERMOSHO'S WE WAS A SUD SEN BLOW
TO THE HEART.
AND WE DON'T KNOW AT THIS POINT,
BUT ELECTRICAL ISSUE WITH THE
HEART THAT WAS UNRECOGNIZED
UNTIL NOW.
AND WE WILL GET THOSE DETAILS,
BUT THE IMPORTANT THING IS THAT
HE WAS RESUSCITATE